Pat Mitchell: Welcome, Jane.
The last time you joined us --
Jane Fonda: Hi, Pat.
PM: It's so good to see you, as always.
The last time you joined us
on TEDWomen, Jane,
I was thinking about that this morning,
you were in the nation's
capital, Washington, DC,
and you were leading the weekly protests,
Fire [Drill] Fridays --
Fire Drill Fridays,
in partnership with
the Greenpeace International.
You got arrested, it made headlines.
and certainly, all of the civil
disobedience actions
brought attention to the crisis.
And I understand that you are restarting
Fire Drill Fridays in December.
What are your goals and expectations?
JF: Well, our goal with Fire Drill Fridays
was and continues to be
to move people from concern
about the climate crisis
to action about the climate crisis.
And we've been successful.
We're coming back
on December 2 to Washington, DC,
for our first live, in-person rally,
which will address the outcome
of the midterm elections.
And we'll talk about what climate activism
needs to look like in 2023.
But, you know, Pat,
we never stopped the weekly rallies.
When COVID hit, we went online
with Fire Drill Fridays,
and last week we had our
11 millionth viewer.
It's working.
People who had never taken action before
have been trained by Greenpeace US
to write and call and visit
their representatives.
They follow up on our calls to action,
they participate in getting out the vote
and volunteering with candidates.
For those in other countries,
you should know,
we have a very critical
midterm elections coming up
in a couple of weeks.
Anyway, so our people
are becoming activists,
and Fire Drill Fridays, by the way,
has become part of Greenpeace.
And we're very honored by that.
PM: Well, there is no question
that it had impact.
And it's really encouraging to know
that you're bringing back the actions
and convening us again.
And I'll certainly try and be there, Jane,
to participate in Fire Drill Fridays.
And you mentioned the elections,
very important elections happening
in the United States in November.
And you have taken some additional action,
another priority, by creating what we call
a political action committee, a PAC.
Explain your expectations
and why you see this
as a necessary action.
JF: Well, after decades of marching
and protesting and petitioning
and civil disobedience,
we still are not getting
the kind of climate legislation
that is absolutely critical.
What we need to do is reduce
fossil fuel emissions.
And, you know, recently in the US,
we got the Inflation Reduction Act,
which puts a lot of money in renewables
like electric vehicles
and the grid
and solar panels and so forth.
But too much legislation that would
have been important has failed
because both Republicans and Democrats
take money from the fossil fuel industry.
And I know this is a huge problem
in all oil and gas producing countries.
And so earlier this year, we launched
the Jane Fonda Climate PAC
with the unique goal of electing
climate champions to office,
not just top governmental office,
but state and local offices
which turn out to be really,
really important.
You know, we have to break
the stranglehold
that the fossil fuel industry
has on our government,
not just here in North America,
but globally.
And that's why we're moving climate
activism into the electoral arena,
which is kind of unique
because we focus down ballot
and because we're trying to change
the narrative about fossil fuels.
You know, everybody talks
about wind turbines and solar panels
and electric vehicles,
but that's not enough.
And my PAC is only endorsing candidates
who have signed a pledge
to not take money
from fossil fuel industry
and who've publicly stood up
and showed courage
in the face of the industry
and not afraid of holding
them accountable.
PM: And that was the criteria
on which you selected the candidates.
I've also noticed some of them,
maybe most of them are women.
Seeing women taking
those front line positions.
JF: Women of color.
Very often they're the first --
the first woman, the first Latina,
the first person under 30,
they’re really breaking
a lot of boundaries,
and they're so brave.
I was just in Texas,
and it's filled me with hope
that will last me for years.
PM: Well, I want to come back
to how you keep that hope alive, Jane,
because it's easy to look at the fact
that climate is not a partisan issue.
And yet, as you said,
leaders on both sides of the aisle
are still taking the money
that's leading to the carbon
emissions challenge.
Why really, do you have a better
understanding now
and can you share it, of why
we have such slow progress
on addressing this urgent global crisis?
JF: Well, I think a lot of it
has to do with the fact
that the fossil fuel industry
is embedded in our government.
People on both sides
of the aisles are taking money,
and so they don't speak out
against the fossil fuel industry.
They only talk
about the green alternatives,
and that's important.
But not talking about fossil fuels
is like trying to bail out a sinking boat
without plugging the hole, you know.
But there's been progress because more
and more people do understand that,
that it is fossil fuels
that are driving --
burning of fossil fuels
that's driving the climate crisis.
And this is really, really important.
The science is very clear.
We have seven years to cut
our fossil fuel emissions in half
in order to keep our global warming
no higher than 1.5 degrees Celsius,
higher than it was before
the Industrial Revolution,
which is when we started
to burn fossil fuels.
So, I mean, I think there has
been progress locally,
especially in states and cities.
They've made progress to reduce
their carbon footprint.
It's just that more needs
to be done urgently.
And the reason that I'm talking about this
on an international forum
like you've provided,
is because I think
that a lot of countries,
I'm thinking of Nigeria, for example,
have the same problems
that the United States does,
they produce oil,
and that we need to be thinking more
about taking the climate activism
into the electoral arena, you know,
recruit candidates and then train them
and teach them about climate science,
and then get them to run for office
and make sure they win.
This is really what the strategy is now.
PM: And you're so right, Jane,
that is a strategy that could be
exported to every country,
because in every country,
or in most every country,
there are elections.
And people can make a difference
by the candidates they support
and encourage to run.
JF: Yeah.
PM: I do think often of your activism
and how you've sustained it,
especially when it comes to this issue,
which sometimes feels intractable,
although we know it isn't.
But when you hear scientists
say seven years,
we're this far away, we haven't done this,
we must do that,
it's easy to lose hope.
It's easy to let fear that we can't do it
replace the hope
necessary to ignite action.
So what gives you hope?
JF: Well, as I said, we have elections
here in the US in less than two weeks.
And I've been traveling the country
supporting amazing candidates
that my climate PAC is endorsing.
You know, we don't have enough money yet,
we're a new PAC,
to play in the Senate arena
or the governorship arena,
which, you know, they cost
a lot of money, those races.
But the down ballot races, you know,
the ones in the state legislatures
and county supervisors
and attorneys general,
things like that, are so important.
And every dollar that goes to those
down ballot races means a lot.
For for instance, in Texas,
the Railroad Commission, oddly,
is in charge of regulating and overseeing
the oil and gas industry.
You know, historically it was
supposed to regulate the railroad,
but then when Texas became, you know,
the massive oil and gas producer,
they switched the responsibilities
of the Railroad Commission to oil and gas,
but they didn't change the name.
So a lot of people don't even know
what the Railroad Commission does.
And historically, all the commissioners,
there's three of them,
they've worked for the very industry
that they're supposed to regulate, right?
Which means they do nothing.
I don't know if people
that are watching know about this
or read about it in the paper,
but two years ago,
when there was an extreme freeze
and the electric generators
failed to produce enough power
to keep the lights on
and the heat running,
I talked to neighbors
who were found frozen to death
in their own living rooms,
and none of it needed to happen.
Extreme weather had shut down
the grid before,
the Railroad Commission had been warned
to weatherize to the grid
and nothing was done.
And still the grid
hasn’t been weatherized.
And so it remains very vulnerable
to another disaster.
So my PAC is endorsing
just as one example,
a young progressive Democrat,
happens to be very handsome,
named Luke Warford,
he's 33 years old,
he’s not afraid to hold the oil and gas
industry accountable --
not to build a career
but to really make a difference.
And if he's elected,
it’s going to change
how the Commission does its job.
And believe me, Texans
and the planet will be safer.
Not only has he pledged
to weatherize the grid,
he's going to enforce
regulations against flaring,
which is a practice of burning excess gas
that releases methane into the atmosphere.
And as you all probably know,
methane is the most damaging
greenhouse gas,
and Texas releases more of it
than any other state.
So this can all change if this young guy
is elected to office.
And then in Harris County, Texas,
Harris County is enormous,
and it is ground zero
for the climate crisis in North America.
And this woman immigrated
with her family from Colombia,
she was elected as the top Harris County
executive, Judge Lina Hidalgo,
the first female and the first Latina
to ever hold that particular
incredibly important office.
And she became a citizen
of the US in 2013,
and she got elected in 2018.
You know, nobody
took her seriously, you know.
Her opponent didn't even
bother to campaign.
But in the four years since
she was elected to office,
she has blown everybody's mind
by how much she's accomplished.
She's holding the fossil fuel
industry accountable,
she's made it easier to vote,
she stopped a highway
going through Houston.
She's changed the way the county works.
She controls a four-billion-dollar budget
and has a robust climate plan
to change how Harris County
deals with fossil fuels.
You know, she believes
that the energy capital of the world
can also become the renewable energy
capital of the world.
And I've seen in the last month
how a big difference my new climate PAC
is having on down ballot races
like Luke's and Lina's.
And this is what thrills me.
This is what gives me hope.
I believe the most important thing
that I've ever done is creating this PAC,
and it's what I'm going
to continue to do till I die.
PM: Jane, those kind of stories
are what we need to hear.
I mean, how inspiring is that, that one
single individual has made that difference
in their community?
And I want to come back to that.
JF: It’s as though
Vanessa Nakate ran for office,
you know what I mean?
What would that look like?
And I'm putting that out there
because maybe she could consider
doing that, you know.
PM: I hope Vanessa is listening,
and if she is, we'll make sure
that she gets this message.
Jane, we have a question from Kat,
who is joining us from the TEDxWomen
in Vail, Colorado.
And you may have done this just now,
but I'm sure there are others, she asked,
"Could you describe what are your most
joyful moments as a climate activist?"
JF: Well, frankly, I got back
from Texas yesterday,
and my body is still humming
with the thrill of working
with these young people.
You know, and it had happened
two weeks ago in New Mexico
with a young woman
who's the public land commissioner,
also a Latina woman.
And in Michigan with the attorney general,
Dana Nessel.
They are so brave,
and they so understand
that fossil fuels is what’s killing us.
And they’re not afraid to stand up
to the big corporations.
And it just makes me --
I can see the future when I'm with them.
That's what gives me hope.
PM: And joy.
We hear from a lot of people,
though, you know,
will say back to a story like that,
well, that person's an elected official
or they've already taken
a leadership position.
And often you'll hear individuals say,
"I just don't know what I can do
as an individual in the community."
How do you respond to that?
JF: Right, well, that's a really,
really important question.
The truth is, there is limited impact
that we can have alone,
and there is infinite impact
we can have together.
So the most important thing
that any of us can do besides voting
is to join with others,
to share our passion
so that we can have a bigger impact.
You know, join an organization,
join a climate group,
get your community or your church group
active on climate.
And you know, the great thing
about doing this work with others,
in addition to having a bigger impact,
it's more fun, it's more rewarding.
We make new friends.
But to answer many people's questions,
when it comes to individual choices,
a recent study has shown
that there is one big impact
of making climate-friendly
lifestyle choices.
Things like, you know,
don't use single-use plastics anymore,
you know, ride a bike
instead of driving a car, etc.
It increases your credibility
as an advocate
for the kind of bigger
and bolder change that's needed.
So, you know, for example,
Greta Thunberg sailed across the ocean.
This had no impact on actual
carbon emissions and climate change,
but it had an impact on people
taking her message more seriously.
And that's a really interesting finding.
So what follows then is that the way
to increase the impact
of our individual choices
is to be sure that they’re visible.
So that if you replace your old
gas-powered water heater
with an electric heat pump, for example,
or you install solar panels
or you use a reusable water bottle,
make it visible.
Tell your neighbors,
post pictures on social media.
You don’t have to be self-righteous
or braggy about it,
but in an inviting way.
"Hey, folks, here's an idea."
You know, make it visible.
PM: And make it personal.
As Mary Robinson also
always encourages us,
do something personal everyday
that moves us forward to a better time.
There's another question, Jane,
that comes from Dallas, Texas.
So I think people in Texas
are paying attention
to the stories you've just shared.
She says,
"It's so important to be able
to identify climate activists,
the ones that will really
fight for legislation
to combat the climate crisis.
So how do we, meaning
we at large in a community,
know and back candidates
who are going to actually
fight for change?
Is there certain criteria
that you're using
and that would stand out for anyone
who claims to fight
for green legislation?"
JF: Yeah.
Number one, do they take money
from the fossil fuel industry?
That is a no-no,
because that means that they're not free
to really stand up
to the fossil fuel industry.
And here in the United States,
in North America,
we have what's called
the fossil fuel pledge,
where many, many, many politicians
and candidates sign a pledge
saying that they won't take money
from these big corporations.
And then the other thing that we look for:
Has the candidate shown courage
by standing up publicly in some way?
Have they opposed an oil pipeline?
Have they opposed something
that might pollute the waterways
in your town or city?
Doing something publicly shows
that you have real courage
and you're willing to stand up and fight.
PM: And looking
for the candidates who do that
and then working for them,
supporting them
and encouraging them to run.
And that can, as you have reminded us,
happen anywhere.
We have another question.
This one comes from New Jersey.
“So many young people
have now taken a stand
to support climate initiatives.
And at times we see their activism
is motivated by fear about the future,
anger towards the older generations
who did so little to prevent
this moment from happening.
What message do you give
to young activists like Vanessa,
and others around the world,
to keep them in the streets
demanding change?"
JF: Join them in the streets.
That's what I did.
I went to DC and got arrested five times
with Fire Drill Fridays,
and we were there for four months
getting arrested every Friday.
We started out with 13 people
getting arrested
and by the time we end,
there was a little less than a thousand.
I mean, it really grew.
Words don't matter, show with your body,
put your body on the line,
and show them that you are willing
to join them in the streets.
We need huge numbers.
Come and join us on December 2
in Washington, DC.
PM: I plan to be there.
Jane, we keep hearing a lot
about the seven-year timeline,
and we know that’s the timeline we have
to reduce carbon emissions
to where they need to be by 2030
to get to net zero by 2050.
In order to do whatever is necessary,
we have to imagine there's a better time.
Some people have actually ...
a wonderful Indigenous leader
actually proposed the question,
Jade Begay, she said,
"What if our best times are ahead?"
And I frankly had never thought of that.
We think so much of the worse future
we are rushing and hurtling towards.
How do you envision what might be
our future, seven years from now?
JF: Well, it's going to take a while
because of all the heat
that's already been baked in
because fossil fuel executives lied to us
about what their emissions were doing,
you know, which they knew
for four decades.
But when I think of how the world
will be generations from now,
if we do what science says we have to do,
I see healthier people
because the air we breathe
and the water we drink
and the food we eat
will be clean and safe.
Nature will begin to return.
Species on the brink
of extinction will rebound.
Coral reefs and dense forests
and snow-capped mountains
that we can see from a distance
will bring joy to us once again.
And our little species, Homo sapiens,
will feel happier and less anxious.
Because, and I hope that along
with confronting the climate crisis,
we will have confronted
economic inequality
and misogyny and racism.
Because, you know,
the climate crisis has happened
because of a mindset of arrogance,
greed and hierarchy.
You know, some things like,
white men are more important,
they're on the top of the hierarchy,
they matter more than people of color
or women or the natural world.
But there would be no climate
crisis without racism.
There would be no climate crisis
without patriarchy.
So it's going to be a beautiful
future if we make it so.
And we are the last generation
that can do so.
And that is an awesome responsibility.
And this is an all-hands-on-deck moment.
So let's all join together.
PM: It's an awesome responsibility
and an awesome opportunity
for us to do this together.
JF: Opportunity, yes, good.
PM: I just have to ask you, Jane,
before we say goodbye,
because so many people have written
about their concerns
of knowing that you are battling cancer,
and we just want to know,
you look fantastic,
but how is your health?
JF: Well for the week
when I have chemo, you know, it's ...
I don't feel like my old self,
but after that, I feel good.
In fact, I feel better than ever
because, you know,
that cancer was in me,
and it was kind of eating away at me,
and I was tired all the time,
and I’m not anymore.
I got strong just in time
for the midterm elections.
I appreciate people's thoughts.
I was hoping my hair would fall out,
or I was going to shave my head
and tattoo "climate emergency"
on this new real estate
that I was going to reclaim.
But cancer activists don't like
to have issues mixed together,
so I didn't want to do it if the cancer
community wouldn't stand with me.
But it's good.
Thank you for thinking of me,
and I'm just fine, thank you.
PM: Well, it's just so great
to know that you are well
and you are continuing this work.
And as Jane reminds me,
and I'm just going to quote her on this,
"Activism is the antidote to aging."
And Jane Fonda is a perfect
example of that working,
not just for her, but for the world.
Thank you so much, Jane,
for joining us today.
JF: Thank you for having me, Pat.
It's great to see you.